in this lesson we're going to talk a
little bit about statistics so
specifically the mean the median mode
the range and the standard deviation so
definitely an important concept you want
to understand for the new revised s80
let's go through these one by one and
then we'll get into some example
problems so basically the mean is
referring to the average you add up all
the data you divide by how many data
points you have that's your average
that's your mean the median refers to
the middle it almost sounds like middle
median middle so what you do is you put
your data in order from lowest to
highest and you find that middle data
point now if there's a tie between the
two middle ones then you add them
together and divide by two you find an
average but the key is to put them in
order from low to high find the middle
the mold is the one that occurs the most
so you look at your data set you see
which one accrues the most say there is
a one that occurs five times and there's
another one that occurs five times then
there would be a tie you would have
actually two modes if they're all just
listed one time each then there's no
mode but basically the mode when you
think of mode think of most and then the
range is really the maximum the highest
one minus the minimum the smallest one
so range is max minus min and then the
scanner deviation is an indication of
how spread out the data points are from
the mean okay from that average so
standard deviations think about how
spread out small of the standard
deviation closer they are to the mean
larger the standard deviation the more
they're spread out from the mean let's
get into some example problems and we'll
get some experience here so example one
says that recent home sales are given
here 100 thousand two hundred fifty
thousand 275 300 thousand three hundred
twenty thousand right but it says if the
$100,000 home sale is removed which will
change the most would it be the mean the
average would it be the medium the
middle one would be the mode or would it
be the range let's see what these values
are first then we'll remove that value
go ahead and pause the video if you can
just one on your own and we'll go
through it together but what I would do
is look at the initial you need a longer
range so the mean is an average we have
to add all these up and divide by how
many there are so let me see if I can do
that on the calculator 100,000 okay plus
250,000 plus two hundred seventy five
thousand plus three hundred
thousand-plus 320,000 and we're dividing
by 5 home sales so it gives you an
average of 249,000 ok now the median is
the middle one so we count towards the
middle you can see it's the two hundred
seventy five thousand dollar home and
the mode is the one that occurs the most
well there's really no mode okay so
until mode and then if the range is the
max minus the min so three 20-100 would
give you two hundred and twenty thousand
okay that's how spread out that's the
range max minus min okay so now if we
eliminate this $100,000 home sale what's
the meaning well let's go ahead and add
them up and divide by four this time
since there's only four so 250,000 plus
two hundred seventy five thousand plus
three hundred thousand-plus 320,000 / 4
we get 280 6250 but what we're going to
do is I'm going to take this and let's
subtract the 249,000 okay just to see
how much it's changing by that's thirty
seven thousand two hundred and fifty so
this is the change right here ok ok now
the median is the one that is in the
middle so you can see now only count
towards the middle it's going to be a
tie between these two here so we have to
add them up and divide by two so two
hundred seventy five thousand plus the
three hundred thousand and we're going
to divide that by two so it's giving us
280 7,500 okay that's the new median but
if we take the difference here we
subtract that's a change of 12,500
remember we're trying to figure out
which one's changing the most now the
mode still there's no mode so you can
see it's not going to this one's not
changing at all that's not going to
change the most okay and then the range
we do 320 minus 250 which gives us
70,000 is the new range now if we take
seventy thousand minus four 220,000 you
can see that to 150,000 is how much
changing by right so which one ended up
changing the most well it was the range
because he that was a change of 150,000
so that's the idea there is just
understanding a different mean median
mode raging standard deviation
definitions and how to apply them so for
example 2 it says given the table below
what is the median value ok so they give
us the volumes but they also give us the
frequency frequency means how often you
know that occurs right so you get 10
twice 12 3 x 15 one time 24 times in 25
eight times so what's the median what's
the middle right and they say is it 12
15 20 or 25 so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can just one on your
own and we'll do it together so first of
all I like to figure out how many data
points there are others 8 plus 4 is 12
13 16 18 so what's the middle of 18 well
it's going to be in between nine and ten
right so if we were to put these in
order we could write like 10 right twice
we can then write 12 three times so this
might take a little while and we're
going to write each of these out what
you would do is you would count towards
the middle if it's a tie like in this
case there is a tie because it's an even
number we didn't be in between number 9
and 10 you'd have to add those up and
divide by two but what I'm going to do
is I'm just going to start from this
from the right hand here and since I
know that it's a tie between me ninth
and tenth one right because I half of 18
is nine but you have an even number so
it's halfway in between nine and ten see
there's eight that are at the 25 value
so nine and 10 would be right here in
this range right here so it's going to
be 20 is going to be your leading values
now if you're not convinced you can go
ahead and do that technique i told you
about writing them out and then find the
middle in between those two but it's
gonna be a little bit quicker if you
realize is that in between the ninth and
tenth values you can count this way or
from this from the highest value to the
middle or from the lowest value to the
middle so again go ahead and review
these concepts if you need to the mean
median mode ranging standard deviation
definitely something important to
understand for the s80 and i'll see you
in the next lesson